yeah I somewhere these you know European
jeans look different they have like
embroidery on it in the back you know
they have like yeah oh oh on the pockets
in the pocket North cuts dad right those
kind of but Ned not only had that but on
his jeans was I guess their embroiders
of Disney characters like in a clump
like it was Mickey Mouse Minnie mom the
back no in the front like Carla coming
down no that's never looked good by the
way
don't [ __ ] with blue jeans don't push it
on right but he had that and I remember
not being brave enough and having the
kind of relationship where I can go to
him go right you just because he's the
headliner so you just accept it but wait
a minute patches did work on jeans in
the in the 70s and late 60s and early
70s the right patches work or iron ons
whatever no patches because those are
sewn on it never worked you know what I
found when I first moved in here an
affliction shirt from you you had an
affliction shirt uh-huh what and of and
a couple of on Dutch whoops you're not
one to speak sir about patches on jeans
thank you you're right all right let's
get back to Chipotle can we go back to
funny it's funny or would you ever not
want to go back to that okay finished
that story
I thought the guy that you're working
with that who who met Carlos at a
Chipotle right there and then we'll go
back so he said he went up to him and
was like hey do you just want to tell
you uh you know I've always enjoyed you
all those in whatever and he just got
real defense it was like yeah okay
whatever do you want me to say I stole I
stole is that what you wanted and he
just got on the defensive oh no man I'm
being looked no dude he's like dude
whatever
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah so
he's also like you said it's maybe it's
gotten to him all these years later I
don't know I mean but in a weird way I
never got to associated with him so I've
always sort of been on the I always had
a thing though like you're just to be
safe
yeah I think felt like I I knew which I
had just this instinct that I think I
got from my dad mm-hm where sometimes
even with other comics not just him I
could have made some money but I was
like I don't trust this dude man hmm
or we did that yeah me that something's
gonna something's gonna turn out man
we're gonna get into it or something so
well it's a it's also a power shift you
have to when you and hence why was the
hottest guy 99 and then not now in 2019
because sometimes those decisions when
you when you take make decisions where
someone could get you in front of mass
audiences and you don't that could be
that could be a breaker right there like
those could have been wow that's a real
interesting thing you just said because
um I don't know I mean I don't know is
it because you do have a pride about you
and that can be that could be a problem
oh wow
Glickman what are you doing I'm doing a
podcast right now with Johnny Sanchez
[Music]
I'm right here brother love you too dude
what's going on monday void men where
man whether play basketball whether play
against it's gotta be like bad will Brad
Williams who's he fighting or playing
Oh
[Music]
Patriots Oh lovely Oh then I'm gonna be
there for sure you just said Grunk up
front I love you know think you sent me
the invite I'll think about it
so what's another I love you I love you
bye Floyd Mayweather against Manny
Pacquiao basketball would get crushed
many Paco's he would destroy him yeah he
bought his own basketball team and he
plays on his own yeah
I would not see I would watch that I bet
that would be better than the fight
fight was horrible yeah oh but we were
here we had a party it was crazy okay
terrible
[Music]